الوقوف على اخر المستجدات واخر الاخبار
والمتابعات معنا من غازي عنتاب مراسل
الجزيره
يونس ياسين يوس اهلا بك نشاهد الخيام خلفك
ماذا عن اهم رصدته في الساعات الماضيه
يونس
قال عبد القادر نحن نتواجد في احد
المخيمات المؤقت التي نصبتها بلديه غازي
عنتاب لاستقبال وايواء المتضررين من هذا
الزلزال الغازي عنتاب لا تبعد سوى 60 الى
70 كم عن كهرمان مراش بؤره الزلزال وبتالي
فهذه الولايه توجد من ضمن الولايات العشر
التي تاثرت بهذا الزلزال هناك يعني مدن
مهدمه هناك بيوت متصدعه
الساكنوها وقاتنوها يخشون من العوده اليها
يعني في هذا المخيم توجد عشرات اكثر من
100 خيمه فيها يعني مئات الاسر المتزاحمه
داخل هذه الخيام السلطات التركيه والسلطات
المحليه في بلديه غازي عنتاب وفرت كل واحد
من ساكن هذه الخيمه وسائل تدفئه اليوم
رافقنا احدى الاسر في محاوله للتعرف على
كيف يتم اطعام هذا العدد الكبير من سكان
يعني هذه الخيام على بعد حوالي 400 متر
يوجد مطعم يعني هو احد افخم المطاعم في
ولايه غازي عنتاب والذي تحول الى بنك
للطعام يوفر مئات الالاف من الوجبات ليس
فقط لسكان هذا المخيم ولكن لعدد كبير من
سكان مدينه غازي عنتاب الذين يعني ليس
لديهم اي مورد اخر للطعام بحكم ان يعني
حوالي 90 في المئه وهذا تقدير شخصي للمحال
يعني المطاعم مقفله بسبب ان القائمين على
هذه المطاعم ايضا لهم هواجزهم الشخصيه
منهم من حاول اجلاء عائلته منهم من يخشى
العوده الى هذا المحل نظرا للتصدع المبنى
الذي يوجد فيه وبالتالي هناك مشكل حقيقي
فيما يتعلق بتوفير التغذيه التغذيه مشكله
تم حله وايضا تم حله على الاقل بالنسبه
لهؤلاء ويكفي ان نقول فقط انه قبل اسبوع
عبد القادر جل من تراهم الان
في الشاشه ربما تشاهد اطفال يلعبون الكره
في محاوله لاعاده ايقاع الحياه كما كان
قبل كنت تقول بان جل هؤلاء كانوا يبيتون
في العرائبون في الساحات العامه خيام يعني
قطع بلاستيك اشعال للنار في الساحات من
اجل توفير التدفئه نحن اتحدث اليك عبد
القادر ودرجه الحراره الان الدرجه او
درجتين تحت الصفر وبالتالي وقبل اسبوع
كانت درجه الحراره اقل انخفاض وبالتالي
فواقعهم بالمقارنه مع ما كان عليه قبل
اسبوع قد تحسن بشكل كبير السؤال الان يطرح
الى متى سوف يبقون هنا الى متى سوف يعودون
الى بيوتهم وهذا يتوقف على اعمال لجان
البحث والتفتيش التي تجوب المدينه مدينه
غازي عنتاب على غرار المدن الاخرى
والولايات الاخرى حيث يتم مراقبه والكشف
عن هذه البيوت ومدى قدرتها على استيعاب
ساكنها يتم تصنيف هذه المباني هل هي متضرر
بشكل خفيف بشكل متوسط ام متضرره بشكل كامل
السلطات التركيه الرئيس التركي اليوم تحدث
عن ان 47 الف مبنى الكره ضربت في المصور
السبعه واربعين الف مبنى تاثر بسبب
الزلزال عشرون الف من هذه المباني صحيح
انها لم تنهر بشكل كامل لكن السلطات سوف
تضطر الى هدمها لانها يعني صحيح انها لم
تتضرر لكنها لن تكون قادره على استيعاب
ساكنه وبالتالي هناك مجهود يبذل السؤال
الذي يطرحه هؤلاء والى متى سوف يبقون في
الخيام والحقيقه انه لا احد يستطيع ان
يجيبهم على هذا السؤال هذا احد المظاهر
والتجليات الباقيه والمستمره فيما يتعلق
بالزلزال بالاضافه ايضا الى المتابعه
الحثيثه لهؤلاء للقصص هذه القصص التي
وصفها تقرير زميل فتحي اسماعيل بالمعجزه
وهي معجزات متكرره بالنظر الى انه نحن على
بعد ساعات فقط من دخول اليوم العاشر من
الزلزال وما زالت فرقه الانقاذ تبحث وتنجح
في اخراج الناجين من تحت الانقاذ عبد
القادر ما الذي سجلته يونس وانت تحتك
ان سواء الذين تم التكفل بهم بشكل تدريجي
بتوفير الماوى وكذلك المطعم او ابرز
الانشغالات التي ما زالت مطروحه الى الان
ممن احتكيت بهم
عدد كبير من الانطباعات الشخصيه عبد
القادر لا ادري اذا كان المقام يسمح بها
لكن جوله بسيطه في هذا المخيم مثلا ترى
عدد من السيارات المركونه جنب الخيام
وبعضها سيارات فارهه وهذا يحيل بطبيعه
الحال الى ما لاحظته ايضا اليوم ايضا في
طوابير الطعام حيث تجد الغني والفقير كلهم
في طابور للطعام ينتظرون الحصول على وجبات
مجانيه اليوم ايضا في هذا المخيم حيث
تجولنا وجدنا يعني جمعيات ناشطه مهتمه
برعايه الاطفال تقوم بانشاء يعني انشطه
خاصه للاطفال ومحاوله التقرب اليهم وطرح
اسئله فيما يتعلق بالحاله التي يعيشون
فيها الاسئله التي يطرحها الاطفال لماذا
نحن هنا في المخيم ما الذي حدث اثناء
الزلزال هناك محاوله ومتابعه للحاله
النفسيه للاطفال وكيف اثر هذا الزلزال على
انفسهم هناك ايضا انشغالات امنيه احد
الذين تحدثنا اليهم في هذا مخيم قال بانه
هو واسرته الكبيره يعني اشقائه وزوجته
وابنائه اخذوا ثلاثه خيام ويتناوبون واحد
منهم يقوم بالحراسه ليليا بالنظر الى وجود
هواجز امنيه هناك مخاوف من يعني ما يقال
عن جرائم منتشره هناك انتشار امني صحيح
لكن ربما التجارب علمتهم بانه الحس الامني
يجب ان يكون حاضرا بالاضافه الى الاسئله
المتعلقه
بمستقبلهم ما الذي سوف يحدث لهم هناك يعني
محامون تاثرت مكاتبهم وضاعت وثائق القضايا
التي يعملون عليها يعني هذا الزلزال حقيقه
الاثار الفعليه له الاهتمام بالاعلامي
ربما خلال الفتره الماضيه تركز على محاوله
انقاذ العالقين محاوله اسعافهم البحث عن
المفقودين التاكد من يعني عمليه الكشف عن
المباني بالنظر الى الخطر الداهم لها لكن
سوف تبقى اثار اقتصاديه كبيره يعني سوف
ياخذ التعافي منها اجلا طويلا عبد القادر
ياسين من احد مخيمات اللواء في غازي عنتاب
شكرا جزيلا لك